[Musique]
c'est presque l'heure du grand bain pour
ces touristes
s'équipent d'abord de palme d'un masque
et d'un tuba avant de plonger au large
de magnetic island dans l'état du
queensland
stéphanie et adam inc ce sont leurs
guides pour la journée ils leur font
découvrir l'une des sept merveilles
naturelles du monde la grande barrière
de corail
j'espère voir une tortue mais aussi des
poissons colorés mais ces fonds marins
qui leur tendent les bras
sont de plus en plus exposés au
dérèglement climatique ainsi en mars
dernier la grande barrière de corail a
une fois de plus été victime d'une vague
de blanchissement massif plus de 90% du
récif a été affecté à chaque vague de
blanchissement la première chose qu'on
veut faire c'est aller sous l'eau pour
en constater les effets se sont comme
nos bébés on veut vérifier chaque petit
récifs et voir comment il se porte la
grande barrière de corail c'est
également une filière employant à elle
seule plus de soixante quatre mille
personnes dans le tourisme et rapportant
chaque année plus de 4,3 milliards
d'euros de recettes
nous dépendons des touristes qui
viennent pour voir la grande barrière de
corail
mais cette manne pourrait disparaître
les vagues de chaleur marine et tend de
plus en plus fréquentes et de plus en
plus intense quatre des six épisodes de
blanchissement constatée depuis 98 ont
ainsi frappé au cours des six dernières
années seulement
le corail blanchi c'est comme une
insolation pour un humain si une
personne fait une insolation temps qu'on
la rafraîchir rapidement elle s'en
remettra le blanchissement du corail
c'est pareil c'est un choc thermique
qu'il vaudrait mieux éviter mais le
simple fait d'en être frappé ce n'est en
soi pas forcément mortelle
le nouveau gouvernement australien s'est
engagé à dépenser au cours des neuf
prochaines années près de 800 millions
d'euros pour protéger la grande barrière
de corail
les deux tiers de cette somme sont
allouées aux agriculteurs afin
d'améliorer leur gestion de la terre et
de réduire la pollution issue de
l'agriculture qui affecte la grande
barrière de corail
dans cette ferme de 13 mille hectares où
sont élevés plus de 2100 cents bovins
cela fait déjà plus de vingt ans qu'on a
adopté des pratiques plus respectueuses
de l'environnement elle consiste à
accorder autant d'importance à la
préservation de la végétation qu'est
l'élevage des animaux
nos principes de pâturage sont inspirés
des grands troupeaux migrateurs en
afrique la bassée grands troupeaux
traverse de grands espaces mais n'y
restent pas ce qui permet la terre de se
régénérer quelles différences majeures 1
s'il ya toujours de la végétation qui
empêche l'érosion des sols
un sujet majeur pour cette ferme située
à la croisée de trois rivières charriant
de grande quantité de sédiments qui
polluent la grande barrière de corail
l'herbe serdar mur à la terre contre
l'érosion provoquée par les pluies on
s'est rendu compte que si nos terres
sont à nu en cas de pluie le seul
s'érode et est emportées par les
rivières
mais pour les plus critiques ces mesures
ne sont qu'un cataplasme sur une jambe
de bois
c'est une bonne initiative mais qui ne
prend pas en compte le principal
problème le réchauffement de la planète
réduire drastiquement les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre c'est en effet le
seul moyen de limiter le réchauffement
des océans et donc l'apparition de
nouvelles vagues de blanchissement du
corail
de destruction du corail c'est
l'équivalent de 10 cyclone de catégorie
5 la plus élevée qui s'abattrait sur le
littoral en se tenant par la main
il faut compter environ dix ans pour que
les coraux qui grandissent le plus vite
se régénère à cause du réchauffement de
la planète nous ne disposons plus de
suffisamment de temps entre chaque vague
de blanchissement
alors que l'an dernier les autorités
australiennes ont versé 7,8 milliards
d'euros de subventions au secteur des
énergies fossiles le nouveau
gouvernement travailliste se veut plus
ambitieux face à la crise climatique
il n'a pas l'intention de stopper ni
même de freiner l'exploitation du gaz
naturel et du charbon mais il promet
dans le même temps de faire de
l'australie une super puissance des
énergies renouvelables en produisant
notamment de l'énergie solaire comme sur
cette immense centrale qui a ouvert à
proximité de townsville en 2018 avec ses
quarante mille panneaux solaires elle
peut générer jusqu'à 116 mégawatts
d'électricité de quoi alimenter plus de
cinquante mille foyers avec das que je
crois qu'il ya un fort potentiel de
croissance pour le solaire en australie
nous avons beaucoup d'espacé un
ensoleillement important cela reste une
nouvelle technologie mais plus elle se
développera en australie + y aura deux
centrales solaires qu'ils ouvriront à
travers le pays
cette transition énergétique a donc déjà
commencé mais il faudra encore de
longues années avant que l'australie
puisse renoncer totalement au charbon
pourtant les spécialistes du climat
rappelle que pour donner à la grande
barrière de corail une chance de
survivre il est impératif de contenir la
hausse des températures à un degré 5
nous sommes tous les gardiens des récifs
coralliens à travers le monde
imaginez que je plonge sous l'eau et qui
n'est plus rien à voir
ça me fait très peur
même en limitant le réchauffement
mondial à un degré 5 seuls 10 à 30 % des
récifs coralliens dans le monde 2 et
survivre en revanche au-delà de deux
degrés il pourrait presque tous
disparaître